(spooky music)
- Are you scared Jason?
(suspenseful music)
- Now brace yourself,
the apartment's small,
a pied-a-terre, but,
[Hermione And Veronica In
Unison] Quality always.
- Are you excited?
Nervous?
- Both. (laughs)
I haven't seen him all summer.
- [Archie Andrews] So,
what was the highlight?
- Of my internship?
The Toni Morrison book release
party I organized, by far.
- Uh, can I sit, Jughead?
- If you want.
- If he is dead, Hal...
I hope in those last moments he suffered.
May Jason Blossom burn in hell.
- Hey, you stopping by the site later?
- Dad, it's my first day.
- [Josie Singing] Lost in the moment
dancing in cages.
- Ooh-ooh.
- Mm.
Excuse me.
This is a closed rehearsal.
- Bro, you are ready for football.
I'm not kidding, dude,
you got ripped.
(suspenseful music)
- Where's the rest of it?
- How are you holding up?
- How do you think?
- Would you like to give
me a quote regarding--
- Alice--
- All right, sweetheart.
- Cooper.
- For the record,
I'm not gay.
- Hey, honey.
Just wanted you to know
it's gonna be a bit of a
late night for us.
(upbeat music)
- Miss Grundy?
Hey.
- Archie.
What are you doing walking in this heat?
- Hey, Pop,
Betty hasn't come in tonight has she?
- No, just the night hawks in tonight.
- Go, get around them, get around them.
(whistle blowing in distance)
Let's move.
Andrews.
(whistle blowing in distance)
- Good morning students, this
is your principal speaking.
There have been many inquiries
about the upcoming pep rally,
so let me state clearly,
it is happening as scheduled.
- Most of you already know the details,
but your classmate Jason
Blossom's body was found
late Saturday night.
(applause)
- Thank you, Principal Weatherbee.
It is heartening to see
so many of you here,
even in weather like this.
- [Chuck Clayton] Let me try again.
- [Veronica Lodge] Let me see it.
- [Chuck Clayton] You don't trust me?
- No, no, no, fine you can take it.
Okay, let me see.
Photo approval.
- I started asking around to
see if what happened to you
happened to anyone else,
if anyone would go on record.
- I will.
100 percent.
- And in that moment of
hesitation, you're dead.
All of you are dead.
- At ease, Doiley.
(dramatic music)
- Okay, okay.
- I'm Joaquin by the way.
(peaceful music)
- Betty.
(joyful laughter)
(upbeat music)
- Mom?
- Hi, honey.
(upbeat music)
- Give me your wallet!
(suspenseful music)
(gun bangs)
♪ My God ♪
- I came home earlier to surprise you.
- Midge Klump.
The Klumpster.
- Reggie.
What do you know about jingle-jangle?
- Forsythe Pendleton Jones The Third.
(camera shutter sound)
- Topaz, let's bounce.
He told me he wants to
earn his serpent stripes,
I say bring us the head
of that North sider
and you're in.
- I'm down with that.
(Sweet Pea laughs and bangs on table)
- We're...
- I know who you are.
The sisters gave me your address
when I turned eighteen.
- Jughead?
- Jellybean?
- Thought I smelled something rotten.
- Jughead?
- Hey, mom.
- Listen, bro, since
we're gonna be cellmates--
- Nice shoes.
I'd keep 'em tied real tight.
- Hi, I'm Everlyn, and you're...
Betty Cooper?
- It's nice to meet you, Cheryl.
- Can I help you?
- Mr Jones?
I'm Agent Smith with the FBI.
Is Betty Cooper here by any chance?